welcome very welcome to this video my
voice is failing I hope my chest is not
failing let's see I'm playing a rapid
game here 10 minutes and 10 second
increment then playing against my friend
Brandon hear the good night on um on
youtube so we're both doing commentary
here you can also check out his video of
the same game um not sure if we managed
to release it simultaneously you need to
need to look into that um okay note that
the rating the ratings here are
something completely unrelated to what
usually is displayed IAM and five minute
chess or or other time controls this is
so-called standard rating time or
standard time rating and I never play
that so my two thousand years basically
the initial rating that every player
gets regardless of his actual strength
and simply basically unrated here
brendan has played a couple of games
starting from the 2001 a couple so this
is something different then the ratings
normally shown you this is not auto
pairing where you get an opponent chosen
by the computer here you can challenge
people like we did here I challenged him
to get this game going yeah and it's 10
minutes base time and 10 second
increment this is very important to note
and this means i have played quickly
gained about a minute of time and he has
spent more time here ok we have them
nims oh of course nimes Oh Indian Z mesh
variation so you plant the cookie 625 I
could have taken actually only five this
would have been interesting it's an
interesting structure but I played d5
quickly that's a bit of a shame i could
have tested this this type of structure
ok not a big deal I'd like to make sure
he does not play if I reform in a recent
publix game I got this if I defined hey
I retreated the bishop to c 2 and at the
end he the opponent got excellent play
with Knight to e5 be sick special basics
not sure it really didn't work out so
well now and this is an interesting
position the interesting factors that
black has not lost em on lost any time
is probably a wrong expression black has
not made any moves with this night on b8
like c5 knight c6 and so now is playing
this I was wondering about the quick f5
like 98 nf5 this maybe was interesting
okay the night the night belongs on g3
in this type of structure anyway so i'm
going to e 2 oh this is ma'am he's
playing us in a bit of a passivation you
can do that but it's not it's not very
active okay neither fa Tessa's plan let
f 82 g6 this is a very solid but also a
bit passive I pretty much I very much
prefer to prepare a five in the
structure to get a pawn break in
yourself but okay if you want to go for
that you're not you're not playing rook
e8 you're not playing that deserve
so he has an entirely different idea he
had an entirely different idea okay of
course I'm pushing the porn CAG 4-h 4-h
6 is really questionable I mean it it
might help to block on the dark squares
but it might also just give me a hook
for an attack this is about this is as
good as it can possibly get in the end
the Samish you gotta close center block
has no play against c4 or the queenside
and i can just push on the King side
without having castle this is a big
advantage that I have the King still
only one yeah just h4m yeah of course
what you can try to do is night fh2 g6
yeah he's some trying that get the night
to g6 at a cage form but but but but is
this really good i can go Bishop e3 96
Bishop to f2 but then then then he may
be he may be halves Queen Queen f6 and
night f form 96mm you know what I have a
crazy idea this is the start of
something bad yeah if it starts I have a
crazy idea it's probably more like a
nonsense idea my idea was king d 2 which
has some merit I mean on 96 i play
Queenie one this is a good one actually
Queen you want to g3 the good way to
play but on kingly to we might play
queen of six and
hmm i'm not sure that i like that now
wait i can't play 93 then this is not
not bad always got queen a fortune this
is bad really bad even okay yeah our
King be too kinky to assess a bit too
crazy but the idea itself is not bad I
wonder let us have something else we add
mean I'm not in trouble or anything just
trying to get the maximum amount of this
because strategically speaking black is
already in trouble and I'd like to
punish it and the best way possible yeah
yeah the salsa night g3 is also not bad
926 just 95 playing this as a pawn sec
also possible way to go King let's check
this briefly again I like I really love
this idea this kinky to get the king
over and and get the Queen involved
kinky to Queen f6 Queen f1 maybe 96
nitin and Queen after a can't stop line
either form but I can i have taken down
I can want to blame this this is just
just too nice not to play it
will be interesting to to learn if you
consider the move I came this is now now
he needs to do needs to be precise i
think if he goes Queen g6 Queenie one is
writing me mouth slip no it's no more
slip um yeah this can actually be a good
move I mean why not why not maybe yeah I
was just thinking about this may be the
the bishop can be a nuisance special
babe form okay right I don't mind I
don't mind Queenie 1 2 g-3 this was the
idea
yeah probably probably this wasn't great
I am if I Keller I really don't care
cannot go to see to this is a bit a bit
of a problem hmm c2 is not a good square
yeah hmm sheriff joe p5 this is
counterplay quite up the slip yeah do
this is what you get for being too
creative just play some normal moves and
have a good position as is better okay
if you place be five now yeah I thought
I can take and place he for again but be
five cb5 eeprom pick and place he for
now c4 is a good move okay I was
thinking that c4 now should be okay for
me and Knight c3 something like that
we need five nights III count king d 2
with sauce crazy yeah sometimes you hit
the bundles those are those weird ideas
until you're simply too fascinated by
that you play it and then okay well it's
just bad yeah most of the so-called
creative moves line in reality just bad
news this is some this is just the just
a fact about chess normally there's
nothing too fancy about it and if you
try something fancy you often punished
how do I get some some harmony in in my
position I mean the problem is really is
the kingdom hmm how do i how do I get
this coordinated maybe maybe just back
here back to f2 or something Bishop d2
in response to Queen a five and then
over to f2 why this is not bad i mean be
five at least them I got rid of my my
double porn yeah this is maybe not so
bad even it would be nice to get
something in like Bishop one Bishop on
c3 one on c2 to cover the B file and
then King f2 look be one switch over to
do that maybe something like that
I don't really have something yeah i was
i was about to say I don't really have
something on the Kings side probably
true maybe maybe I can do beyond this is
maybe an idea maybe I'm threatening g5
in this position g5 mmm like yeah okay
then this is not bad actually I was
thinking about g5 he plays h5 yeah and
then f form if he captures Bishop takes
a thought I'm basically winning these
six but he has rook v6 which is very
important of course okay get get the
King get the King to some safe place or
at least a safer place
pick up c 2 s also a move that has some
merit cover the sensitive a form I'd be
three squares but I fido bishop c2 and
then move my see one Bishop is quad
rugby too okay let's not get ahead of
ourselves he needs to move as well and
sometimes you're in a situation where
you you think too hard about your own
plan and then your opponent gives you
the opportunities and presents you with
the ideas by his moves so of course it's
good to consider your possibilities but
once in a while that son his point is to
be to concrete about it and just think
think about some general ideas and then
see what he's doing yeah I have this f4
idea that this can be very very tricky
like f 49 f6 also also possible okay so
is it if I play the bishop somewhere to
e3 maybe Andrew p1 get this exchanged at
the end is maybe night to g6 and then I
probably need to close the position hmm
not sure it's 35 g 5 + f4 maybe okay
this is sharp but I'd like to to get
something going here I don't want to sit
and wait if we if I go f four he takes
Bishop takes I'm threatening here on d6
or the rugby 60 playbook be one just try
to exchange the defenders of d6 if it
does not take I'm prayer playing a five
and this is such an overwhelming space
advantage I cannot believe that black
can't stand that on the other hand if it
takes let's just briefly think about
night f4 okay neither for that's h5
hanging but he's got Bishop g4 ok I'm
plying going for this just attacking b6
I don't believe he can ignore it like
you look be two or something I can just
take it this is too much yes I think you
needed to do that and now a rookie move
maybe this one I way the fist playing
rook to e8 I can take the six right I
can take him oh is this is this not a
good material win takes Queen takes
Queen takes group takes root PA this is
very simple and winning but rook takes
the scum compensation after Luke takes
p8 like with 96 35 I cannot do that i'm
on beard gathered i can take
Candice was really shaky after king d to
this was far too creative I think he
lost a bit a bit too much time here like
what sir it was okay especially right
after kindy tool I mean maybe there was
some more frost will play yeah I'm
talking about the game like it is
finished already it isn't but it's very
yeah I don't really see any way for him
to to stir up trouble him he must play
rook takes t6 know otherwise I just win
even more material 26 is an endgame
completely completely losing so he needs
to take with the rook rook be eight then
yeah the problem is that he cannot move
the species they cannot move the f-89
the rukon v8 is nicely pinning the night
on her head
hmm my last move now
if he moves the Queen I just take be aid
and it's I it's a whole look then
it's cool back resins yeah yeah this is
really hopeless i'm not i'm not entirely
sure what where the maybe maybe in this
in this position you should black shirt
should do something else okay p.m.
here's the point yeah i think here at
the point i think we could try see form
this is a possible idea i'm not one
hundred percent sure but this is
something i would consider winning some
tempe and then take here making sure
that it gets open to the position
something like that the key the king on
d 2 is so it's really a bit of a crazy
piece the computer wants to immediately
evacuate ya hear i'm not i'm not sure at
all I mean here here I think white is
better again to be honest maybe maybe
this one trying to to play on on c4 like
like this night hear something I don't
know it this Bishop d7 I mean now I'm
correcting my king position and it's
it's basically again a position with the
space at 12 gent the bishops
yeah of course here Ruby aid is just
losing a compounds to play this and
funny enough gives it as equal this is
how to believe that this should be equal
maybe yeah 196 is coming that maybe
maybe it's not not that clear yeah maybe
I can enter here but what exactly is my
next my next move iam yeah this is still
playable for black no no doubt I have no
I have no real win okay when I didn't
want to sit and wait all the time I
wanted to to open the position and it
turns out it run the game relatively
quickly but yeah maybe this means i
should do something else here i'm not
quite sure what i mean if i don't do
that that probably shouldn't play gt5
yeah maybe one roof off like v1 or
something
yeah this position is not it's not the
end of the world black I mean it still
feels like white should have something
but it's it's a fairly solid set up
fairly solid okay i hope you liked it
and you can also watch black players
commentary on the game the good night is
a channel on Emma put it a description I
put it in the description the link
thanks for watching